Visa borneo's most famous residence and
this land is intended to be a Haven for
the endangered species
the sambotia La stari Center
rehabilitates injured and orphans
orangutans before they are released into
the wild
but even in this Sanctuary they still
face threats there is a lot of illegal
mining unfortunately in this surrounded
Samuel study so this is quite dangerous
for the establishment of the
conservation unauthorized land
encroachment is a major concern for the
foundation altrianto hopes the
Indonesian government's plans to
relocate the capital to a location
nearby will result in more vigilance
against long-standing environmental
problems such as deforestation for
Mining and palm oil plantations
the new capital Nissan Tara is due to be
inaugurated in August next year this
will be the main area of the new capital
said to be a sprawling Metropolis four
times larger than the current capital
Jakarta authorities say Nissan Tara will
work with rather than against nature
the government has pitched the project
as a model for sustainable development
you know that the development of the new
capital is not just
making the new cities it's not just a
building infrastructure but it also to
restore the degraded environment
this Nursery is part of that initiative
seedlings grown here will be replanted
in usantara
we are actually transforming industrial
forests back into natural forests
because the president wants 60 percent
of the new Capital Area to be green
some are skipped skeptical groups like
Greenpeace have criticized the project
we must think about modern development
just the core area development will
destroy more of the natural environment
other conservationists have raised
concerns about the clearing of hundreds
of hectares of mangrove forest for
infrastructure to service the new
capital and the impact on some endemic
species but back at the orangutan
Sanctuary aldrianto says he can also see
the positives this is like an
opportunity in the hand of the
government as well to showing to us that
government also care not only moving to
escalimandan but I'll also seeing this
is the eagerness of the government that
the conservation should be
10 as important as a development of our
country
the challenge for the government is to
prove it can reverse some of the
environmental damage of the past and not
create further destruction along the way
Jessica Washington altazira east
kalimantern